then i got a question for you to start
here
so you are surrounded by a pretty
phenomenal ensemble here of course
angelina included so
what is something that she did while
making this movie that you kind of want
to put in your back pocket and take with
you to your next project
oh just the energy of it she was always
so
you know white on set um she she was
she was there to work and she was so
professional but she could also you know
she could
sit down and have a joke and have a
conversation with you and she was really
inviting and friendly and i found that
very calming on set on such a big
production
angelina i was reading about some of the
stunts that you did yourself and i know
you've always emphasized the importance
of doing your own stunts which
kind of made me curious at what point in
your career did you realize that
there was great value in doing all of
that yourself
when i did tomb raider for the first
time i was i had this i had three months
i wasn't sure i wanted to do the movie
until they said to me
you i said i really didn't feel like
that character suited me i actually
didn't at first
want to do it i said no but they said
you can you can travel the world and
train with the british military
and uh and so i had three months of
seeing what i could do and i would i
would encourage anybody to do that sign
up for as much as you can give yourself
a few months push yourself to limit and
see
what can i do and uh you find that
there's a lot you didn't know
and some crazy weird things you you you
can do or you're
uh capable of and um so i love it and i
do think with the more we have
in film that's uh visual effects the
more it's important to do your own
stunts if you can because i think the
audience knows the difference
and it just it feels real when it when
it is
it you know makes more authentic
absolutely
finn i'll throw that your way now is
there any stunt that you did yourself on
this set that you're particularly proud
of
jumping off the fire tower with angelina
on the rope that was an amazing day
just just going for it was
super fun and i had absolute faith in
the system that they were using you know
wade allen the stunt coordinator he was
absolutely great on set um and i found
it
really amazing that um taylor sheridan
the director would let me
you know do that because he really puts
you he really lets you do it so that you
can understand
the stress and you know everything that
that go that um
the characters are going through even if
it is you know super fun and i know it's
safe
you know connor is just
super scared at that point and it and it
helps you you know get into the
character a little more
so angelina before they kicked me out of
here i was wondering what it was like
for you watching
chloe jowl make history at the oscars
because
it was probably one of my absolute
favorite things that happened this past
year
yes it is yes it was i was i was
thrilled and i know her
i we all know her talent i'm fortunate
to say i know her as a person
and uh and she's a she's a great lady so
so it's uh deserving in many ways it
made me very very happy
always rooting for her and huge
congratulations to both of you i really
thought the movie was excellent so thank
you for your time and congrats
thank you perry